you can tend to become a generalist in
lots of different Industries and not
have a particular expertise in any
single one so here I would say at least
based on my experience at McKinsey I'd
say it's kind of right and wrong at the
same time it's right in the sense that
of course in the beginning you will not
be a super deep expert in one specific
topic and yes if you really switch
industry to Industry then will be quite
hard for you and will take some time but
the other side of things is that
especially if you decide to early on
pursue projects that are specifically in
one industry only I would argue that you
will build industry expertise much
quicker and much more deeply and the
reason is that you will do projects in
all different types of companies of that
industry seeing lots of different
functions in the industry working
together with very senior employees